so it's not just Donald Trump who's
increasingly unstable as a result of the
recent impeachment inquiry and the
corresponding Ukraine Fiasco and
everything else that's going on Trump's
a lawyer Rudy Giuliani also seems to be
unwell he went on Fox News the other day
starting to hold up a pad of paper to
the camera shouting about some
completely fake scandal in which Barack
Obama is now supposedly implicated and
it made for extraordinarily entertaining
television which also confirmed how post
fact we have gotten Rudy was interviewed
by Fox Business host trish regan and to
her credit she asks mostly terrible
questions but like a couple times she
actually asked a good question which is
hold on Rudy setting aside all of the
other details why was Donald Trump at
all involved in getting trying to get
not just Ukraine but also China to dig
up dirt on Joe Biden and Rudy is
incoherent and doesn't answer check it
out there's a lot to unpack here so to
start us off in trying to attack Biden
Rudy literally defines bribery is done
by Donald Trump if that was a one-off
we'd have a highly unethical conflict
contrary to what Joe Biden said today
there was no conflict even the New York
Times said there was a conflict yeah Joe
Joe really kind of lost it today I don't
know if you saw the clip but he got very
very angry reminded me of some of the
people I investigated when as the US
attorney wasn't it but the reality is
that what happened in Ukraine is is if
seen as a one-off could be an isolated
case of technical bribery offering
something of value in exchange for
official action is the classic common
law crime of bribery Biden did that he
offered 1.2 billion dollar loan
guarantee threatened to take it away in
order to intimidate a strong-arm is his
word the president of Ukraine to fire
the prosecutor technical bribery
offering something of value for official
action like Trump said we want the
deliverable if you deliver a Biden smear
we will get you hundreds of millions in
military aid got it thanks Rudy for
clarifying that let's continue here Rudy
starts going into Joe Biden's corrupt
and the Obama
might have been filled with this type of
corruption
it's the Clinton Foundation it's Obama
it's all of it says Rudy he got elected
vice president and then they monetized
his vice presidency for hundreds of
millions certainly tens of millions of
dollars it's just too often it's just
too frequent it's just too many times
saying I don't know my family's business
when his family's business was in the
newspapers no interest he should know I
mean it's not a conscious it's corrupt
as heck that's what it is it's big it's
a big scandal it's a big pay-for-play
scheme it raises the question how much
more like this was going on in the Obama
administration it sure sounds like the
Clinton Foundation to me where they were
selling out the country and getting
donations to the Clinton Foundation and
Obama was she I don't see it what what
is he talking about bummer Clinton like
what is this guy talking about
and then trish regan gets to her
question why is Trump involved in this
and here's how Rudy defends it and
notice that there is no answer in what
Rudy Giuliani says okay so then the
question becomes yeah okay conflict of
interest maybe may be far worse I mean
to your point could be much worse than a
conflict of interest but then why is the
President of the United States asking
about it why is he doing any digging why
doesn't he leave it to you know you and
others to do all that why get involved
because this came up not having to do
with Joe Biden running for president it
came up to me in November of 2018 over
almost a year ago when several
Ukrainians reached out to me through an
intermediary and told me I wouldn't
believe it for a year and a half they've
been trying to give us evidence that
more collusion took place in Ukraine
than in Russia where they believe no
collusion took place so I jumped on that
because Trish I'm his defense lawyer if
I were doing this for a terrorist those
phonies in the Senate and the house
would be defending me remember Trish
Regan's question was why was Trump
involved in doing this and Rudy
justifies his own involvement in this
and then trish regan tries again but why
was Trump personally involved in this
but you know that the concern is why why
was it even why would your name come up
in a conversation with the president of
Ukraine why would president Trump be
talking about Rudy Giuliani actually
technically you are right sir I'm not
sure I ever know you're right you're
right I saw the memo on the transcript I
read it the highlighter and all bring me
up yeah what is it let me bring up
because for five months before actually
eight months before I had been
investigating Ukrainian collusion once
again Rudy can talk about whatever he
wants but there is no answer there about
why Donald Trump was at all involved in
this nonsense then asked about why he
doesn't have evidence of this he says oh
well of course Biden had the evidence
destroyed and removed obviously I don't
have the rest of it because Joe Biden
bribed the president of the Ukraine who
then had the next prosecutor dismissed
the case that contained that evidence
called the aunt act case along with
Purisima along with Biden's son I wasn't
looking for Joe Biden the Ukrainians
gave me Joe Biden and they said do you
know something he interfered with your
case
I hope it's coming through that these
are the rantings of a madman I mean
quite quite I'm being serious about this
if you're watching you're probably
noticing that the interviewer trish
regan looks visibly confused by what
rudy giuliani is saying that's because
rudy is making no sense and still giving
no answer to the question why is Trump
involved in this and he keeps up with
this the Ukraine stuff can't you just
say Ukraine it's not the Ukraine and
then Rudy wraps it all up with his
rapid-fire
rhetorical questions where there were a
lot of drugs and a lot of other problems
and you don't think we think you're
corrupt you don't think we think that
your country is hypocritical and don't
you think the President of the United
States has to vindicate that don't you
think we have to straighten it out
article 2 section 3 of the Constitution
something that these Democrats have
trashed says
the president of united states has the
obligation to take care that the laws
are faithfully executed joe biden trash
the laws of the united states to the
embarrassment of my country and i found
that not because he's a candidate for
president he was only thinking about it
then I found it and I started my career
and maybe I'll end it rooting out
corruption at the highest levels of
government and I've done Republicans and
Democrats ride man Rudy just making no
sense and it's sort of funny because
Rudy will often be interviewed by other
Fox News hosts and when like Hannity
when Sean Hannity interviews Rudy
Hannity interrupts all the time and to
steer the conversation and to refocus it
and to also add his own perverse spin to
the stories trish regan doesn't do that
she lets rudy giuliani talk and he comes
completely unglued as a result of it
hopefully someday we will have a full
accounting of how rudy giuliani even got
himself into this position with donald
trump in the first place because it's
totally incoherent it makes no sense
it's not clear what rudy giuliani is
talking about and as far as clarifying i
think the whole point of this interview
is let's clarify the biden thing let's
clarify your involvement let's clarify
the president's involvement and things
were less clear for sure
after rudy giuliani finished his
conversation on fox business